back to a guy like this i don't know if
i disagree with uh uh matt by the way
and a part of it is the following here's
a part of it is this a real story
uh
yeah this is a revolution to undergo
cancer surgery yeah that's a real story
putin has cancer yes sir yeah is this
actual facts yeah the first time i'm
hearing this no no this is uh
we've known he's been sick but i don't
think we quite knew exactly yeah russian
if you want to read the article go back
to the top so i can read it so
make a little bit zoom in a little bit
more russian president vladimir putin is
about to undergo surgery cancer surgery
and temporarily hand over power to hard
line former federal police chief
according to a new report putin will
transfer control of russian government
to nicolia patruchev
head of russian federal police security
council while he is incapacitated during
and after the procedure according to a
video from the mysterious telegram
channel generalists we are on saturday
the channel which is
perpetual uh reportedly purportedly run
by a former russian foreign intelligence
service lieutenant general known by the
pseudoname
viktor
mikholovic reported that putin has been
told by doctors that he must go in
operation now who knows what's going on
here as well you don't know what this is
some big news what kind of cancer did
the article go on and say what type of i
thyroid cancer oh that's not good i i
think that's why he's been putting on
weight the past couple years and let me
let me do some more research into it
i'll get back to you
yeah but but the reality of it is the
following if you push the guy in a
corner
he's not a guy that's not going to do
anything no he the only thing the only
saving grace is the following he's got
kids but he would get his kids to live
somewhere else unless there's
retaliation
and he loves his country he truly loves
russia and he knows
if he did anything to america
he's going to destroy so many of his own
people
and he has to privately by himself say
are you okay with that do we know he
loves his country though i know he said
to soldiers to be slaughtered and you
well like massive numbers does he love
us those are those are the most loyal to
this country yeah but you can say the
same thing about every you know does
truman really love his country when he
did that you gotta ask a question but i
don't i think so
that to me goes to he loves the ideas
of what russia meant to him way before
what it is today he loved that his
loyalty is to that like to him it was an
insult saying who were you to think
ukraine's not part of russia i'm sorry
you are russia like his ideas
is the og ideas of back in the days not
the new progressive ideas that you know
some folks think that russia have i
think that's where he's gonna go and say
you know whoever he admires like
everybody has somebody they admire
that's dead right think about who you're
gonna say like who you wanted to make
proud right is his gonna be a stalin or
a lenin or a father or somebody that he
worked under kgb i don't know
but he's going to say i'm going to meet
that person one day
is that the would my loyalty go to
something like that i don't know so my
the only saving grace i have is that
when he gets to that point he's not
going to want to do it because it's
going to backfire in ways that it's
going to get very very ugly it ain't
going to be just from america i think he
would say something like russia i love
you we all have to die together
nothing you think that's the angle i
think i think because i love you so much
i must destroy the plan i think it might
have been oliver stone who was here i
saw that so that was really interesting
i'm not sure if you've ever worked with
oliver known or been in the mood i know
a little bit about it i'm sure you do
yeah yeah uh and i remember i said who
does he want to emulate who who are his
heroes is it is it stalin is it lenin he
goes no no no no no
he older than that mother russia i think
he said peter the great
and this is what year were peter the
great i mean this is czarist russia in
the 1600s so when we talk about what his
i do think he loves his country i don't
think there's any doubt he loves russia
um
when but when we think of russia and the
russia that he loves it's not soviet
communist red russia of the 1930s
it's the
1630s 1730s whatever you're what year
was peter the great
okay early 1700s
uh
that is the greatness that putin wants
to
bring
that's the first thing i said peter the
great was six eight wow damn pretty back
then that seriously but that is the uh
the russia that i think putin wants to
make great again so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]